mesdames et messieurs si votre corps
quel combat commence comme mavericks
regardez qui est là moi qui croyais
qu'il prend avec les meilleurs messieurs
voici blackman ahlmann si tu veux mais
cette mission c'est quoi
on est les meilleurs pilotes au monde
qui pourrait bien être notre instructeur
capitaine de vaisseau vite mavericks
mitchell
je vais être franc
n'étiez pas mon premier choix vous êtes
ici à la demande de l'amiral kaczynski
alias ice man nous semble croire que
vous pourrez encore servir la navy en
quoi je ne sais pas
sauf à toi respect monsieur je ne suis
pas instructeur
je voudrais pas que vous vous fassiez
trop d'illusions
ces messieurs
si votre commande
et c'est reparti on ira dans 3
à
on va devoir se battre comme aucun
pilote ne l'a fait avant nous
même pas lui
là haut tu penses tu es mort fait pas
confiance
mon père avait confiance en vous je
ferai pas la même erreur
[Musique]
on s'en sortira pas tout suivre
ce sont des pilates
leur arrive quoi que ce soit
tu ne te le pardonnera jamais
plus question de reculer
c'est rien c'est que l'échauffement
[Musique]